قضت محكمه في بوسطن بالسجن 42 شهرا على
وليام بريك سنجر الذي يوصف بالعقل المدبر
لعمليه فساد مالي تتمثل في دخول ابناء
مشاهير واثرياء جامعات مرموقه مقابل رشا
ماليه قبل ان ينكشف امرهم او ينكشف امرهم
في فضيحه هزت قطاع التعليم العالي في
الولايات المتحده وجهت التهم الى نحو 55
شخصا في مقدمههم سنجار الذي تقول سلطات
انه تقاضى نحو 25 مليون دولار من الريشه
دفع سبعه ملايين من هذه مدربين الرياضيين
ومسؤولين في جامعه لادخال ابناء الاثرياء
الى تلك الجامعه وقال مكتب المدعى العام
الفيدرالي في ولايه ماسه ان المحكمه ايضا
يعني يدفع المودان اكثر من 10 ملايين
دولار لمصلحه الضرائب الامريكيه امرت كذلك
بمصادره اصول تزيد قيمتها عن خمس عن خمسه
فاصل ثلاثه مليون